the Joe Rogan experience get out of here
yeah he's the crazy [ __ ] speech at
the Bernie Sanders Rock get out of here
like one of them goose bumpy speeches
whoo he seemed to run the jewels I I get
goose bumps I get like a physical
reaction to their music it's so powerful
and killer Mike president killer Micah
runs for president everybody runs for
president human being yes he's a
powerful orator like a [ __ ] New Age
preacher when he was doing it that
birdie said texting him like dude that's
some serious [ __ ] you know like he was
he was spitting flames brilliant man
there's something about people that
could do that right they can have those
[ __ ] giant speeches and that's one of
the reasons why Trump is successful is
his ability to stand in front of large
groups of people and get big reactions
but he says dumb [ __ ] he does but but
it's all in who's your audience you know
it's all in like who's there and what
else have they heard that night right
that might be the most fun [ __ ] they've
heard that night if he it's like if
you're a bad comic you know a lot of bad
comics do they have terrible comedians
open for them so you have like just like
the audience is just in a coma by the
time they get up in a sense that's what
Trump is Trump's a comic who said
nothing but shitty comics on before him
so all the politicians inform them even
the most interesting ones are really
boring to listen to talk to for long
periods of time but Trump goes up there
and it makes fun of Mike Bloomberg hype
i ducking under the [ __ ] table and
and he calls Hillary crazy Hillary lying
Hillary and sleepy Joe Biden he makes
jokes about them I'm not saying I'm not
justifying what he does but the reason
why he could even do what he does is
does everybody besides him when it comes
to communicating is so goddamn boring
yeah the way they get their message is
so [ __ ] boring yeah
Jesus you're [ __ ] killing me you're
so annoying with the thumb thing you
were talking like that in my house I'll
be like who the [ __ ] are you man who are
you why are you lying about your past
why are you pretending about this you're
gone it's a weird sleight of hand you
know yeah for something they're wearing
a mask killer Mike there's no mask no
he's guns blazing oh yeah that kind of
person is the future oh man
that's what's gonna happen back to the
truck it's like a it's like a magic
trick but so is everyone else that's the
problem
the problem with saying that is so is
Ted Cruz everyone saw the videos with
Ted Cruz with his family like you know
pretending to have like a real moment
was family weird weird like sculpted
fake scripted reality Trump is the
antidote to that that's the problem
they're all crazy - that might be a
worse kind of crazy
I think it's tricking it's like someone
someone made a good description of it I
think it was Kyle kolinsky that's
exactly what was he was saying it's
exactly like there was a bunch of crappy
comedians that were imitating the
cadence of Dave Attell he always had
these brilliant punchlines and he he
inspired a whole gigantic slew of people
that have imitated this Dave Attell
cadence most of it is harmless and
they're just fans and they wanted to be
like him they might not even realize
they're doing it and they eventually
would find their own voice and that
happens I'm sure with musicians it
happens probably with everybody and are
in everything right but the problem is
it's like just just doing something like
that is I can't listen you can't run the
world if you're
doing a character if you doing this
because you're trying to make it as a
comic and you pretending you're Dave
Attell fine but if you want to run the
[ __ ] free world and you do in the
Obama thing and you're talking like this
and you're talking the exact cadence
exactly the way old Barack Obama used to
talk like [ __ ] you man that's not you
who are you [ __ ] who are you
at least we know who Trump is he might
be crazy it might be madness man I think
it might be you're right
guess what they all want the whole
thing's crazy yeah everybody wants to be
President
almost everyone yeah except a couple of
them you know what I like [ __ ] wants to
run this thing crazy people
[Applause]